why why can't fall asleep avoid
electronics before bed blue light from a
screen simulates daylight and causes
your brain to produce cortisol a stress
hormone that wakes you up do not nap
during the day with every waking hour
your body's desire to sleep increases
not being resets your sleep drive and
can keep you awake at night have a
regular sleep schedule even on weekends
your body has a natural biological clock
called the circadian rhythm sleeping in
or staying up late can disrupt this
rhythm and make it harder to fall asleep
the next night don't drink alcohol
before bed as alcohol leaves your system
it disrupts your restful REM sleep and
can even cause nightmares use your bed
only for two things sleep and sex using
Pavlovian conditioning you can
strengthen your body's association
between bed and sleep remove work TV and
phones from your bedroom bed equals
sleep also
when orgasm releases oxytocin and
vasopressin two hormones that lower
stress levels and improve relaxation
keep your body temperature cool your
body's temperature naturally decreases
during sleep you can help it out by
lowering your thermostat and not
exercising before bed
sweet dreams